a [ __ ] guardano le belle ragazze
benvenute questo video sono fallite sono
tornato nella mia vecchia camera era da
un sacco che non riportava rocket league
ho fatto un episodio sono cat league con
ciccio gamer età cha abbiamo fatto i
culi i culi veri sono capito mi piace a
buona visione
si parte martedì mattina no ci aspetta
che questo gli scritti o buttati giù
bravissimo parato e mamma hanno spazzato
renon o tifosi cosi tutti mi youtube
raga 10 mar la fascia bello senti banco
[Applauso]
la macchina p nicolaiano bene allora
come numero di ore ma di come la sidebar
è fallo per noi ora dove voglio io sono
importa la bravo bravo è oggi una
stoccata
caro gigi anche scritture animali ma
l'hai oggi vasta scala
bravo farina l'ho fatto fuori anime tua
madre una donna che uomo buono mi piace
questo privato fino al tu non lo so c'è
3 tocca menomare controllo livello raga
non è possibile non è possibile volare
le nudo occhio toccate e i segnali e poi
da un ottimo difesa dice mai catino sì
sì già o dio per levarmi gli occhi che
ti amo il torchio aiuto io gli ho tolto
non chiacchiere questi quattro forni se
questi si tocca la minima o dio per loro
e litio e questo no [ __ ] a guardare
ragazzi io l'ho sempre detto lorenzo
surrogati league è troppo forte
non c'è niente da fare
[Applauso]
eccolo cosa sto facendo niente agati
aprendo un conclusivo vorrei dirvi
ragazze la incredibile ostacolare ho
fatto io ho fatto io
vai vai così adesso ci giochiamo poterli
bella ti voglio cattivo come l'angelo
[Applauso]
ancora quelli stiamo dobbiamo farli
soffrire lavoriamo ci vogliamo
peggiorare visto allucinante sbagliato
arrivederci a bergamo 20 che volete che
sia dama o in maniera non prendiamoci
per i fondelli è spostato tutti futuro
ho i brividi per le parate veramente
male secondo la juve i temi come potevo
prenderlo e ragazzi dai 18 cala ciccio
di toccarla è molto bravo molto bravo
ho visto ho visto mio meglio per una
sega è presente non è rimasto in mezzo a
una ricca di reati vari
proprio i ricorsi su linee capire un
attimo qualcosa che lo sa mai che col
dai gol ma lo fa niente non ci vieni
purtroppo diradate tirato niente stiamo
riponendo ha detto niente ormai viene
solo la porta
allucinante voi quale pericolo anche la
nostra porta
bravissimo bene così anima allora vocata
rocca via mancino preso il togo lo
scaldabagno è vero tanto questa vinciamo
questa giunta tuo agio
basta madonna via maggio famiglia nel
campetto sotto casa vai vai vai vai vai
se guardo montana ci abbiamo contro ma
chi è che col motore ma dopo il booster
del motorally vedi come come gira meglio
roba da qualche pezzo ddl ma è reattiva
e 10 cantico dai effetti vai vai giù
alla lontana c'è il suo a napol questi
chiamanti sua nota merda mia volta
vai a anima controllata avventandosi
solito come l'ultimo a vedere orniamo di
jana montane iniziative di svago i bar
erreg11 due fiori svenuto ho visto fare
una cosa dice che l'affitto ubriaco e ci
siamo dove ubriaco è entrato dentro la
porta fatto cose
di sognare di più dov'è la lista nera la
non la sbaglia il pallone re occhiaie
all andrea pirlo anima bella che avete
più soldi ma ed atene le mazzette fa non
poter giocare sa bene ai colori e nei
just friends col rientro di nessun
risvolto canterà veramente l'innesto
guardami secondo stessa di prenderla
vano mancata analisi mallamaci top è
stato software se ne hai fatto tutto ha
guardato guarda me io sono tu arabica
tatuaggio è bastato quindi ragazzi
questo era il grido con sasha e ciccio
spero vi siate divertiti io sono sempre
nell'oscurità più totale però e agosto e
piovono anche i sassi quindi non ci
fosse un panetto di una giornata di
merda però spero che video vi sia
piaciuto più dopo la mia foto con il
pannolino visto che interessa molti però
che vi sia piaciuto con la sento se vi
piace momento mi piace anche il comitato
dall'architetto salvare ci si chiede e
noi ci rivediamo ad un prossimo
pannolino braga
[Musica]
no